what's up guys scar here from the store
it's here with Reginald old ex-player
current owner of TSM the biggest League
of Legends or brand ever so how you
doing right now Reggie your team's
currently two and O in a playoff setting
about to go into the finals I think
we're doing good we're tool right now
but you know anything can happen we've
been actually I don't think there's ever
been a case in our history where we've
been reverse sweep but uh you know I
don't be going overconfident is a new
patch and so we're feeling really
uncomfortable with the patch when the
patch was issued right before playoffs
we were really nervous right because a
lot of our guys put so much work into
the regular season and they're
practicing at least thirty to forty
percent more than other teams so they
got really burnt out by the end and then
when there was a huge reset
what happened was we fell pretty behind
and everyone came into playoffs on an
even level like we're going even against
everyone in scrims and then towards the
end of it we started winning more and
more and more and by the end we were
winning like 7080 percent but it wasn't
like that the start of playoffs what do
you think about these crazy patches that
come in I know right does like midseason
and preseason are supposedly supposed to
be the big patches every year but last
year they had the juggernaut patch where
they introduced game plank Darius
mordekaiser before worlds and there's a
running joke that Corky gets buffed
before worlds and right before playoffs
and this rules they change one b-2s
could like extremely and so now it's
like completely different like what's
your personal opinion on these types of
last-minute changes well I mean if you
look at it from a fan perspective right
they have a lot of fun watch watching
LCS and worlds of new champions and you
know it just gets all crazy you see a
bunch of new champion seed arias and GP
running around my just killing everyone
but like from an owner perspective and a
player perspective it's honestly really
discouraging playing in LCS when there
are these major changes right like I
would probably say it's like the click
like in order to make like an uneasy an
example I would probably say it's like
if you look at like the NBA right where
they go into like the NBA Playoffs it
would be essentially changing like the
basketball so basketballs weight and
changing it to like shooting a bowling
ball instead of a basketball
and a lot of my players um practice like
10 to 12 hours a day and you know it's
all fun practice either because they
wake up at like 10:00 they do Vadra view
to 10 to 12 and they scream from 12 to
like 9 p.m. and then they play silly cue
they're pretty much really invested into
this rate and all their hard work
essentially goes away and so from us
like a spectator standpoint it seems
really funny when people don't know what
they're doing and they're playing all
these champions but like at the same
time you know like from a player
standpoint an understand point I said it
was discouraging because you know they
spend their whole entire lives and most
their time practicing and essentially uh
with just like within like a second
without any notice at all the whole
entire game changes and so that's like I
think that's a big reason why you see a
lot of player burnout and why players
crews are sort right like I know what's
your opinion on it you played as a pro
so I sucked for me even when I was
playing so yeah I think right now people
are grinding a lot more and it's getting
to a point where I do agree the average
pro player life term is 2 to 3 years so
it seems really uncomfortable because
you can't really think too much about
the future and I think that that sucks
because I don't know what kind of
applicable skills you can have playing
this game and like rotating into another
kind of profession I kind of speaking
about the patch a little bit like what
do you think where I could do to change
it do you feel like they should just
make big changes like kind of like
preseason midseason or just like before
the season starts and then make like
really really small changes leading up
or do you feel like it's ok to make big
changes as long as it's not at a really
really shitty time like like before
playoffs or before worlds like before
like let's say msi i mean for my
standpoint like I said I think it's it's
absolutely ridiculous
because yeah yep you have to think about
it from a player standpoint and the way
they change the patch is they completely
changed the way the competitive scene is
played I mean it's it's more fun for
sure encourages more team fights it
makes the game more exciting at the same
time from a competitor side it also
actually removes a lot of the strategic
value that our our players have spent
time practicing on like for example
right now because there are so many team
fights and teamfights dictate the game
more than like rotations
having a good shawl-collar and having
someone that understands the game is
nearly as valuable and the reason why we
were so dominant the split was because
you know double if and bjergsen they
proved the shock calling by a lot they
communicated really well the rest of our
players also keeping kid really well is
a huge team effort and we weren't better
players but as a team we understood that
patch way better from like a ride
standpoint you know they said they've
told us many times that they are only
balanced
bouncing around for the game itself and
I thought it was really interesting that
they said a huge president to change the
competitive side of things um right
before playoffs right because if you
think about it that patch that they
issued mainly changes competitive play
more so than solo queue or casual play
because everyone's still playing
standard lanes anyways but whereas in
competitive play you're able to play tv1
and tv2 and when you have like a matchup
that wasn't that had a disadvantage you
can just swap out at the right timing
and base but because that is gone it
probably removes the complexity and the
strategic side of the game by probably a
really really huge margin it's a lot
more simple now you know what do you
think what the critique that people say
that the best teams the best players
should just learn to adapt because I've
heard that even last year when last
worlds came around people like oh it's a
new patch well players and teams should
just learn to adapt to the new patch
because that's what they didn't pick
that's what they're getting paid for
like the best players can always add
adapt to any situation I mean I think
that comments right because
first off like from an outside
standpoint it's really easy to say that
but they don't understand how much
effort and time the the players have to
put into learning the game it's like
essentially if you go to school to
become like a math teacher and then all
of a sudden you find you find out like
six months later that you have to like
teach science otherwise do a lose your
job that's that's basically what it is
right because I don't want to get into
too much but the way the system works um
if you get relegated you're done and
because the Challenger scene is a week
if you get relegated you pretty much
lose everything so uh team owners are
really quick to change out players and
when a patch is issued a like a really
great player can all of a sudden be
really bad right and they have to
practice their ass off in order to get
really good again by putting the time in
and you know putting the ten or twelve
hours a day
days a week is not sustainable uh you
know they're like a couple exceptions
right like bjergsen faker double of
where they've consistently been really
good but most players they fall out fall
big in this patch I know in scrims like
a lot of our players are having really
difficult problems adjusting to the
patch and the reason why they're able to
do that is because they just simply
practice and put more time in than
everyone else but the way competitive
else League of Legends is it doesn't
really reward like um knowledge you know
like if you do if you're like a doctor
or I can't list a good example or not
but if you're like a doctor and you
practice your profession for ten years
you become a commander at what you do
but an LCS it's not rewarding because
from a pro player standpoint you you
learn something you really get at it and
then you basically lose everything that
you've learned in the last year and I
mean League of Legends at its basic like
glass hanging in the stuff everyone is
proficient at that so it's all about
understanding like how much damage a
champion does what's the max you can do
right so I mean to go more into it you
have to sorry OB
so to go more into it I mean as you as a
competitive player when you play on the
competitive side of things it's not as
fun as you think you have to understand
all the matchups so if you play like
Diana yet to understand all ten matchups
that play into damage so if you like
Viktor and Cassio and like aurelion
solar and meta right now and everyone's
playing it you have to understand how to
apply Diana into all those champions
right so when a patch changes every
champion that you pie you need to learn
the ten matchups that each champion goes
into so it's a lot more complex than
that and it's really grindy and scrims
are really stressful because when you're
doing bad everyone's upset and it's not
as fun as like going home after work and
playing a game so I mean to that comment
I just don't think people are that they
don't have the information to really
judge the situation but they they they
think like playing games and being an
eSports players always fun which is not
the case it is really rewarding to be
able to do what you enjoy but the same
time they don't understand the the the
difficulty in like adjusting and I'm
like me as a player I hated it I'm sure
all of our players hate it too we
definitely didn't like the huge patch
change and I mean I sound pretty salty
and I really
you know being such a big org since you
guys have likes great infrastructure you
guys are the biggest org in league does
that mean that and you guys are having
such big problems with this patch does
that mean that other teams also are
having like equally bad if not worse
problems than you guys yeah so from a
big org standpoint I mean I think that
we run into the same problems every
single year it's just how we put out
that fire we put it out a lot quicker
because I mean I've invested six or
seven years of my life into this right
most of my adulthood and so I like when
LCS or one like season two our season to
transition to LCS I I didn't understand
what was happening but um but what
happened is it's like a half open half
closed system so which I don't think
works that well because if you get
relegated you lose everything so
basically because I put so much time and
invested so much time into it if I get
relegated I pretty much like lost a lot
of the work that I put in so I'm always
on top of it when we're doing bad I'm at
the team house I'm making sure that they
go through everything I'm making sure
our coaching staff you know I light a
fire under them basically I'm always on
top of it that's why we've been able to
take top two for so long but it's every
like three months I'm super stressed out
all the time
because it is I mean it's a scary
overall all about like to answer your
question from like a lower organization
standpoint like a lot of the investors
are buying into the buying into eSports
because they don't understand how to
navigate around and they don't
understand what to do it's a lot harder
for them so they're losing millions of
dollars by putting money into some they
don't understand and that's with any
investment right if you like if you
don't understand a space and you put
money into it then you're just basically
taking a gamble um but they're they're
they're they seen the same problems
right like they don't understand who to
recruit they don't understand how to
prove their players and they aren't able
to like pull in money so they're just
scared I would say for me uh more I'm
more hands-on about it so I don't have
to worry as much but it's not like it
improves because of how drastic the
patches are um
I don't necessarily always get better at
running my organization
I'm just there's just always a fire lit
under me so it's like 24/7 you know I I
guess I'm not explaining it that well so
that's all right talk to me a little bit
about the franchise system and like
about like you talked about how teams
can't really make revenue like if you
kind of expand on that because uh
because there's been a lot of talks
between all the team owners about
franchising and whether or not you know
it's possible and obviously everyone's
always like of course the owners weren't
franchising because they're gonna be
like so much richer without it but from
what I understand you have a like I have
a different point to bring up well I
mean that's a touchy subject Gregg
because I know like the community
doesn't like it and it's a it's a tough
subject battle you know I don't think
that's like a huge problem did you end
up watching a Monty's video yes I did so
I mean I like to put a short rate it's
it's just an unstable environment
overall and I think that if if we wanted
like a system where it wasn't there
wasn't franchising and it was an open
system it would be better I would prefer
like a completely open system or a
completely closed off system because
it's I would say it's really volatile
for the organizations and the players
like I mentioned earlier when I use the
example of like investing into
profession and you really put focus on
it right like if you want to be you know
a news anchor or whatever it is you put
time into it you slowly improve through
the years and by the by the time you're
in it for 20 years you become an
absolute star and you're not nervous in
front of camera anymore
I kind of want that to be like my career
in eSports where I have I'm investing
into something stable and I think is
this a combination of the lack of
revenue and also how unstable the
patches are that really makes things
volatile in terms of investment
perspective right like um like from a
fan perspective because a lot of them
are going to watch it's it's really
scary to own an eSports team um because
the patches change a lot and so when you
own a team and the patches change in a
really unfavorable way for your players
then there's a higher chance that you'll
do bad and you can get relegated so I've
structured TSM in a way where I'm always
always looking out and I'm always
adapting and that's not necessarily a
good thing because it doesn't really
create me and
come for the players any comfort I would
say but like back to the franchising
side of things the guy a lot of the guys
are investing to this they are not able
to build a stable organization because
that you know the board is always moving
rate and they don't understand how to
like go towards like the moving target
whereas for me because I I understand
how to go towards it like roughly I'm
able to be constantly successful but
because like the the targets always
moving and they can also like lose their
spot it's it's volatile so I would
prefer to see more stable patches one or
two patches per year that scheduled
around competitive play I think that
would really benefit the players a lot
and there's a lot the second thing is
you know if there's no franchising I
would just like to see um you know hire
like higher pricing and like more
infrastructure for the players and for
the teams well I I would just prefer
something more stable I don't
necessarily think that franchise is the
key but if there was no franchising then
I would want to see a more stable and a
better Challenger scene um but a huge
issue is the the revenue opportunities
for the teams and that's like I don't I
don't really want touch on that too much
in this interview I mean I want to say
thank you for your time but do you have
any last words you want to say you've
been around this scene for a long time
so you have any wisdom you can impart on
anyone who watches this interview oh
well I think that a big part of this
interview is you know me being really
upset about like the patches and I I
just hope like players are a lot more
receptive I mean all players all fans
are a lot more receptive to like teams
completely formal like crap after a
patch right because if you look at like
last year in summer we did really well
I am Katowice and we took first and then
when we went back we got completely
stomped because the game changed great
and if you look at this year happens
exactly to CLG and the reason why is
because the season is so intensive
you're applying 10 to 12 hours a day for
three months and then if you take first
it's actually if you took first is
actually more brutal for you because now
you have to practice after the season
for two weeks you have to go to msi and
then after msi you put you're playing on
a new patch so you have to grind it
again and the and then when you go into
summer you're just completely burnt out
and then you play in summer and
there's a new patch you grind it out
again that's not sustainable that's why
um that's why you know you see like
really unstable performances
uh like immortals this year they're hoon
is really one-dimensional right so he's
really good at playing aggressive
champions and all of a sudden you know
the meta is about like gnar and echo and
being tanky and he's warned about like
burst champions he probably a better mid
player to be honest laughs anyways uh
the game changes a lot and so the guys I
put a lot of work in don't necessarily
get the benefit to it you know
CLG Bernero law I could tell so I
actually feel really bad for them
because I understand from their point of
view like they had no break they went to
spring they were underdogs everyone just
made fun of them and made fun give it to
you and 60 a lot of which I mean
they're not the greatest players but on
the spring split patch their teamwork
was better than everyone else and it was
a team game so they want and they
deserved it and you know we're not gonna
take any of any of that away from them
and then when they went to summer they
just I mean you saw all right they got
abused and then they practice their
asses off and start trending upwards by
the end and then a whole other patches
gets launched on them so I'm here
complaining about my conditions I'm
practicing hard
I'm pretty sure clg's I would say like
more upset about the change but if I
were to issue any changes I think it
should be right after playoffs when all
the teams have qualified so it doesn't
become an instance of you guys practice
for a whole entire year and then you
find out you're actually not playing
what you practice for a whole year
and I just find that like really
unacceptable but I don't really have a
say towards this so well I mean I also
agree with you I hope that there is more
stability in the scene
I'm here with Reginald from TSM I'm scar
from the squirty-squirts you can find
more content online and on our mobile
app that you guys hope you guys have a
nice day
you